And in the world trade centers I've been accused of covering up and I don't like
that.
Okay.
You'd be,
what he does is he's been accused of covering things up of,
uh,
being a bullshitter,
not looking like I'm covering.
A lot of people think
hologram planes.
A lot of people think you're a Zionist shill.
You know that that's the biggest one.
That's the biggest one about Alex Jones.
You know,
I'll be honest with you,
the biggest one people always be,
and you know what?
I always have your back always,
always.
I said,
you know what?
If I didn't know him,
I would prob probably think that shows is the show.
I know you,
you are honestly,
uh,
making it a mission in your life to a search for the truth to,
you're all about liberty.
You're for real.
You want the best for people.
You're looking out for the people's best.
So whether you're right or wrong,
it doesn't matter.
You're right.
You know,
sometimes you're wrong.
But when you only want to say you're old.
So it's hard for me when I'm,
like I'm saying,
I always have your back.
It's hard for me to to think you're like,
some sign the show.
I'm like,
I know what this,
listen man,
people make up rumors about all kinds of people.
They,
they,
they'd come up with ideas that they want to push.
They decide,
you know,
accused someone of doing something really stupid,
like being a part of something that they're not.
Here's the best way.
I,
you your back Alex.
A lot of heat for it,
Michelle.
They think I'm a Zionist now these people,
when you,
when you [inaudible],
when you see conspiracies against you that you know aren't true,
does that make you distrust conspiracies?
Well,
I told you that's the part that's the evolution of you between now and you under
a lot of stuff as lies,
but then people that just say everything's bs,
you got to check it.
There's a lot of that going on.
Right?
Exactly.
So let me try to answer any questions.
Your questions are excellent as well.
And the two go together.
I eh,
I mean I grew up in Dallas,
Texas in the eighties and nineties when it was like the murder capital of the
country.
I lived in a middle class area,
but it was still like,
and you know,
I got in fight,
we're rednecks.
I,
you know,
I got in fight with,
with racist Mexicans.
There were racist white people attacking Mexicans.
But I,
I mean I had a big black guys attacking me.
They were like three grades in school and my black friends will say,
man,
you're so cool.
You're not racist.
Even though you know,
my cousin who's 18 or if you're like 14 years attacked you and you know,
that was all just part of a development.
People do tags.
It doesn't care what color their skin is or where they came from.
There's good black people,
there's bad black people,
there's good white people,
there's bad white people,
there's good Mexicans,
there's bad Mexicans,
just good Asians.
There's bad agents,
there's good North Koreans,
there's banner North Koreans.
And I'm standing really simple stuff.
Everybody knows.
But I'll go to a restaurant if they've got good food.
I don't care if it's Ethiopian or if it's Mexican or was chairman.
If the food's good,
the people are nice.
I love it.
Like a women,
like I love black women or white women or Hispanic women.
I Love Mall.
Like if a cool,
I know a bunch of black women that are bitches,
black women that are cool.
What about Swedish bitches?
The point is let's just say I'm,
I'm Super Gay,
but the point is what I'm getting at here though,
not like sweetest.
Let's wrap this up.
Now we eat a wrap it up,
but I've got to make this point.
I don't know what it is.
How is that getting into that?
Oh,
the racism thing.
it's not about,
and I want to say something so similar,
but he's like,
yeah,
you just told me grass is green.
Martin Luther King.
Like it doesn't matter what color someone is.
It matters what they stand for,
what they do.
I go to restaurants that can be owned by Koreans or black people or white
people,
whatever.
If the food's good music.
I love Jimmy Hendricks.
He's a black man.
If the food sucks and I hate it,
but it's not because they're white or because they're Hispanic.
Of course,
Joe,
I don't see going next to a Mexican for three hours,
a 100% believe you totally love Mexicans.
I do to
Mexican food to the show.
We've had a big epic interview.
It's been pretty,
God damn good.